hi everyone i'm abby welcome to abby's
kitchen and welcome back to our series
enlightened by intuitive eating in our
last video we discussed principle number
nine of intuitive eating
exercise feel the difference so if you
haven't watched that video yet
go check it out and then come back to
watch this one now before we get started
i want to flag that this content may
not be for all of my viewers so feel
free to take and leave what you find
valuable
i also want to remind you to check out
evelyn tripoli and elise rush's book
which i've linked
below and a big thank you to intuitive
eating dietitian alyssa rumsey for
reviewing this content
i'm gonna be leaving her contact in the
description below so that you can reach
out if you're looking for any one-on-one
consults
let's start with our viewer question
dear abby i chronically overeat because
the food just tastes
good not because i'm dieting or
restricting and binging
but because i just love food and i can't
seem
to stop how is it possible that
intuitive eating would ever work for
somebody like me
this is actually a very common question
so i thought that it would be really
great to address it
in our last episode here now there are a
few things that could be at play here
first it's important to remember that
it's okay to eat past the point of
what's comfortable fullness for you
intuitive eating
is not the hunger fullness diet
sometimes
foods just taste really super delicious
and we just
want to keep eating no matter what and
that's okay
there are also times where we may not be
physically hungry
but we're taste hungry so we eat things
anyways
and that's okay too the other thing to
think about here is that
even if you aren't dieting or physically
restricting food
and you're allowing yourself to eat all
the things
if you're still actually mentally
restricting then you may have a really
hard time
stopping when you feel physically full
mental restriction and scarcity thoughts
include things like
oh i'm not going to snack this afternoon
because
i always eat so much when i do or i'm
only going to eat when i'm
super hungry today or i've got to stop
i can't do this overeating thing again
even if you're not physically
restricting
these types of mental restriction
thoughts have the same effect on our
body
as if you were dieting your body gets
the message that restriction
may be kind of on the horizon which
makes it really hard to stop
eating when you feel full it can also
trigger your body to increase your
appetite
or your cravings because it thinks that
food scarcity is actually coming
to stop mentally restricting instead
come from a place of abundance
when you view food as abundant plentiful
and aloud and reframe any mentally
restrictive guilty thoughts
it will be easier to stop when you're
actually physically full
instead of i always overeat i need to
stop try telling yourself
i'm allowed to have this delicious food
whenever i want
and then follow through by allowing
yourself to eat
the next time that you're hungry and you
want it this permission
and abundance along with some
mindfulness to notice and enjoy the food
reduces the urgency and needing to
finish it all
right in one place now let's get into
our final video on intuitive eating so
in this video we're going to be
discussing the last principle
principle number 10 honor your health
with gentle
nutrition now a lot of people argue that
intuitive eating doesn't make sense for
most people
because it doesn't teach people about
what is actually good
to eat for your health that is actually
not true intuitive eating is an approach
to health and well-being
that does actually include nutrition and
movement as we talked about last week
intuitive eating isn't about eating
endless amounts of chips and candy
it's about ditching the diet mentality
and establishing a healthy relationship
with
all foods it's about getting rid of the
guilt
and enjoying all foods as they were
meant to be enjoyed
the 10th principle of intuitive eating
is about using gentle nutrition
to help honor your health this principle
is last
for a really good reason the reason we
need to put nutrition kind of on the
back burner
until we can establish some of these
other primary principles into our life
is because if you're still stuck in the
diet mentality
learning more and more about nutrition
may feel
kind of more like another set of
guidelines or rules
and those tend to trigger our body's
starvation deprivation response
and we just continue the diet cycle even
if we aren't necessarily
trying to diet it's important that we
unlearn
diet mentality and process other
principles of intuitive eating first
so that they have time to kind of
marinate and solidify in our life
when you've made peace with food tuned
out the food police
and are able to make food choices
without fear
or without guilt then you can start to
work on adding in gentle nutrition
unfortunately our society today creates
a massive
fear around food you don't have to be a
chronic dieter to fear food
in fact i guarantee most of us see
food phobic messages on social media
multiple times a day
whether it's a list of foods to avoid
for weight loss a video claiming that
celery juice will cure chronic diseases
or cnn telling you about the newest
study headline that certain food
components can cause
cancer we are constantly bombarded
with messages purposefully or
subliminally
telling us to fear food with a constant
fear that food
may hurt us many people are becoming
obsessed with eating
healthy and although this may sound like
a good thing
the obsession of only eating clean
or healthy foods can easily feed into
the development of
orthorexia defined as an eating disorder
marked by an unhealthy and rigid
obsession
with healthy eating orthorexia is
becoming a huge problem nowadays
and we see a lot of signs of it online a
quick look at some of the top youtubers
and instagram influencers
and you'll see them obsessing about
every little calorie
and every little nutrient to the point
that it's pretty much
all that they talk about they start
avoiding anything with sugar or
processed ingredients then they cut out
any added oils
then they shun ingredients just because
they can't necessarily
pronounce them in an ingredient list the
list goes on
and on if you take a look at different
cultures you'll actually notice that
this obsession surrounding food
is much more prevalent in north america
than it is in other nations take france
for example
the french are known for having a
massive focus on pleasurable
delicious food and yet have
significantly lower rates of chronic
disease
despite being the capital of croissants
and wine and butter
one of the theories explaining this
discrepancy is that france
and other nations focus more on food as
pleasure
rather than something that we need to
fear and restrict if you've ever been to
france or italy or similar european
nation
you'll notice that the food culture is
very different
people take breaks during the day to sit
down and have
a luxurious lunch dinner is not in front
of the tv
and can last for hours with family and
friends eating is considered a social
event
rather than a chore that we have to do
many times a day
and people know how to savor every bite
overall their food culture is much
slower and more deliberate
while north americans tend to eat food
very quickly and usually try to
multitask at the same time
the point is it seems the more focus and
fear we put on food through dieting
and the less time we spend on enjoying
food through intuitive eating
the more likely we are to damage our
relationship with food
and ultimately our health in fact while
nutrition science has evolved
significantly over recent decades
health seems to actually be on the
decline according to the world health
organization
in 2001 non-communicable diseases
contribute to 60
of global deaths in 2016 this went up to
71
of deaths globally in fact in high
income nations like canada and the u.s
nine out of the ten top causes of death
were from
non-communicable diseases like heart
disease stroke
dementia copd cancer diabetes and caving
disease
another thing to keep in mind is that no
one food will lead to bad health
just like eating a salad won't magically
shed 10 pounds eating food that has the
label of
unhealthy whatever that might be won't
give you heart disease or
cause weight gain food is so much more
than just numbers
its flavor its texture its culture its
social environment
pleasure tradition and so much more
reducing it to a simple calculation
cannot account for any of that and all
those things play a really important
role
in our health in fact there is some
interesting research that shows that
eating with others
can improve our nutrient intake one
cross-sectional study of over 8 500
people
found that those who ate alone were less
likely to meet their daily nutrient
needs
in contrast those who ate in the company
of others were more likely to get enough
nutrients throughout the day
interestingly this didn't mean that
people in groups
ate more calories they simply ate more
health-promoting
nutrient-dense foods now one of the
biggest critiques of intuitive eating
is the notion that encouraging people to
eat ad libitum
encourages them to eat unlimited amounts
of food
and ultimately drive themselves into
poorer health
the thinking is that without rules and
structure
we somehow can't figure out how to eat
without going
completely overboard but let me put this
question
out here how come diets which are
written with rules and guidelines
don't work how come so many people
aren't able to
stick to a diet long term certainly
under this theory having rules and
guidelines to stick to
should give us the willpower that we
need to push through right maybe not
research has shown that dietary
restraint is linked with
more weight gain than intuitive eating
is in fact
intuitive eating is associated with
better nutrient intake
lower body weights improved health
parameters like heart health
as well as an overall better
relationship with food
with research even showing a reduction
in disordered eating thoughts
and behaviors contrary to what they
think
intuitive eating is not linked to
excessive food intake or weight gain but
you know what is
extreme restriction i mean you've seen
me talk about cheat days on this channel
a lot
and i think that that is a textbook
example of
what happens when we restrict the foods
that we love
one day we crack at the site of a
cupcake and we end up eating the entire
whole box of cupcakes in an all-day last
supper event so now let's focus on how
intuitive eating can
authentically promote health first is
achieving authentic health
when you finally get rid of any
lingering diet mentality
and remove morality from eating you can
actually start to focus on how
certain foods make you feel
interestingly
this can actually lead people to just
naturally
choose healthier options more regularly
because they tend to feel
more energized have fewer digestive
issues
and just have better concentration
overall
maybe they also sleep better and they
just feel more alive
in contrast eating an entire big
family-sized bag of chips followed by
an extra-large pizza and polished off
with three sleeves of chocolate chip
cookies
doesn't usually feel so good for most
people
but eating a colorful salad with some
protein some grains and some fats
and something for dessert is both
physically saturating
and emotionally satisfying leaving you
feeling great both in body
and in mind research also actually
supports this
people who identify as intuitive eaters
have a higher diet
quality than dieters do and if we look
at children who are naturally intuitive
eaters
we see this too as long as they're
provided with a variety of food options
they will naturally just meet their
nutrient needs
over the course of a week without any
external parental influence or pressure
at all as i've talked about before
allowing yourself
unconditional access to all foods
including the ones typically demonized
by weight loss diets
almost never leads you to only eat
junk food rather you may enjoy it a
little bit but
after a while your body will just
naturally want you to eat something else
remember my holiday example if you've
ever been to a resort
you'll know that the first few days are
filled with like heavy buffet items and
unlimited drinks but after like the
third or fourth day
you might start unconsciously adding
just more vegetables
onto your plate i mean as humans
we like variety and this is no
exception but you might be wondering
with so many competing recommendations
what is healthy eating anyway well
according to evelyn tripoli and elise
resh
healthy eating is having a healthy
balance of foods
and having a healthy relationship with
food
the gentle part of gentle nutrition is
really important
and is reflective of the flexibility and
permission
that is so integral to intuitive eating
having that flexibility and groundwork
set up by the other principles
is what allows you to truly explore and
find what feels good and works for you
individually the key is that you're
making the choices from a place of
honoring your health
not from any lingering diet culture
motivations
yes of course an apple is going to have
more nutrients
than a chocolate bar obviously that is a
given
but having a healthy relationship with
food means that you can enjoy an
apple or a chocolate bar and not feel
like
one choice somehow is just a better
reflection on your character
up until now we've really focused on
developing a healthy relationship with
food
and i hope that you have started to work
on some of the strategies that we've
discussed
but we've been focusing mainly on your
inner thoughts feelings
beliefs and physical sensations like
hunger and satiety cues
but of course to achieve authentic
health it's important to embrace both
your inner
and outer world your outer world
consists of things like
nutrition and exercise guidelines
philosophical preferences
like eating local or eating plant-based
or environmentally friendly
as well as other factors from the
outside world
though these are very important it is
key to focus on your inner world first
and then slowly apply the tenants from
the outside world
like nutrition so if you're still
working on your inner world then i would
really
take the following information with a
grain of salt
and come back when you feel that you're
ready to apply it into your life
let's go over one of the major
considerations that i want you to take
home about nutrition
and no it's not eat less gluten or sugar
focus on adding more variety with gentle
nutrition you want to think about
adding in instead of taking out in the
world of dieting we are told to
eliminate foods or food quantities so
it may seem really strange to be told to
add more types of foods to your diet
i want you to just take a second and ask
yourself this question
how has eliminating foods served me has
it made me happy
has it given me the energy and the
health that i'm looking for
chances are for most people the answer
is no
when you eliminate foods or food groups
not only do you increase
chances of a binge but from a
nutritional status perspective
you know you also increase the
likelihood of nutrient deficiencies
but when you focus on eating a varied
diet you'll be better equipped to fuel
your body
with enough nutrients to stay healthy
and stay
vibrant years of negative food messages
can make something like vegetables
fruits or even fiber seem synonymous
with dieting
when you've reached a point in your
relationship with food where you can
make decisions
from a place of self-care like hey i
know vegetables provide me with
nutrients that my body needs
instead of from a place of self-control
aka i have to eat vegetables with this
meal or else i'm not being healthy
once our choice is coming from a place
of self-care
we can have more flexibility to explore
new foods
and new cooking techniques as well if
you've never craved vegetables but have
gone to the point where you know all
foods can fit and are available to you
trying out different recipes and kinds
of vegetables to add to your meals
and noticing how they make your body
feel can be a really great way to
practice gentle nutrition
variety can also come from trying new
foods switching up your seasonings
or testing out new recipes a good
starting place for working in gentle
nutrition
is to look at what you currently eat and
see if there are any ways or areas that
you might be interested
and willing to incorporate some more
nutrition often i'm asked
well abby if i don't track my nutrition
or carefully follow a meal plan
how can i be sure that i'm getting all
the nutrients that i need
every single day the goal doesn't need
to be to get the same nutrients every
day
but instead look at things over the
course of a week
the truth is our bodies are extremely
smart and adaptable
for example if you don't have enough
iron in your diet for a bit
your body will start to absorb more of
it naturally
if you have too much vitamin c your body
just gets rid of it
through peeing not to mention nutrient
recommendations are literally just
averages your body's unique needs are
very different from your neighbors
and they also will vary year to year
month to month
day to day and hour by hour seriously
people
our bodies really do know what is best
for us and can easily adapt through
absorption
and excretion to make up for our
imperfect calculations
and if you're eating a varied diet and
not eliminating too many things
it's very likely that you just naturally
will get what you need over the course
of a few days
once you keep this in the back of your
mind the urgency of needing to eat
perfectly starts to disappear and you
can focus then on eating a diet full of
balance and variety
now you may still be wondering what
should i do
if i'm trying to eat healthier then i
would focus on
three main things taste
quantity and quality first is taste and
yes this is the first thing i want to
talk about
when it comes to eating healthier how
many of you have gone on a diet
and hated just about everything it
wanted you to eat
like come on people cauliflower is great
and i
love cauliflower but it doesn't have to
be in
everything nowadays healthy food
isn't that enjoyable for a lot of people
it's always free of something that made
the food taste good to begin with
or you're only allowed to add a drizzled
dressing or a pinch of cheese
but never actually enough that you can
actually taste it
interestingly there is research that has
shown the importance of health food
labeling
and how it influences our perception of
the eating experience
in one 2006 study researchers showed
participants different boxes of crackers
that were labeled based on made-up
nutrition facts
so for example one box was labeled to
have higher amounts of
unhealthy fats while the other box was
labeled
healthier despite differences in the
boxes the crackers were
exactly the same at the end of the study
the researchers found that
even though there were no difference in
the crackers themselves
the participants automatically just
automatically assumed that the
healthy crackers were less tasty and
that the unhealthy crackers
were way better tasting even without
even trying them
this goes to show that our society has
created an inverse relationship
between healthy food and flavor but it
doesn't actually have to be that way
i actually want you to focus on making
your food always
taste good i always say healthy food is
only healthy
if you're actually willing to consume it
so there's no point in making a bowl of
plain steamed brussels sprouts
if it's literally just going to sit on
the table untouched
and if you do eat it it's not likely
going to be very emotionally satisfying
so you'll just go hunting for something
else until you find something that hits
the spot
you know you want the cupcake so you say
okay i'll have the grapes
so you eat the grapes but it's not
enough so then you eat chocolate cereal
that's not quite enough so you go eat
the chocolate bar you find the bottom of
the pantry somewhere
and that's still not what you actually
wanted so that you finally cave
and you eat the cupcake along with the
other five left in the pack
had you just had the cupcake you wanted
you could have cut out
all that flavor hunting and probably
saved yourself a tummy ache
too so on that note if you enjoy having
a bit of cheese on top of your salad
you shouldn't feel guilty about that in
fact if it makes eating a nutrient-rich
salad more enjoyable
you're actually just more likely to eat
it and you should feel
great about that if you want to make
pasta using regular pasta noodles
instead of whole wheat pasta noodles
that is totally fine i mean as long as
that doesn't take away from your
enjoyment of the dish
you're catering to both your nutritional
and flavor needs
i always think about this concept in
terms of my toddler
if i want my toddler to eat something
nutrient rich let's say
salmon okay i'm gonna make it taste as
damn
good as i can i'm not going to give it
to him
unseasoned and steamed i'm going to
maybe
add like a crispy coating or a sweet and
tangy sauce in there
why are we still dragging ourselves
through boring steamed
unsalted fish we are worthy of flavor
too
so i want you to remember that flavor
enhances our eating experience
and makes naturally nourishing and
satiating foods
satisfying again for recipe ideas feel
free to check out my website which is
full of delicious ideas
also check out my book the mindful glow
cookbook which i will leave a link to
in the description below okay next let's
talk quantity
so next thing i want to talk about is
quantity which i think is key in your
intuitive eating journey
and maybe not for the reason that you
think when it comes to food
i actually want to make sure that you're
eating enough food to satisfy your needs
when we're hungry and constantly under
fueling it can be really hard not to
make frantic decisions
about what to eat and that is often when
overeating tends to occur
it's also important to remind ourselves
that chronically under eating
can lower our metabolism while
simultaneously creating a sense of kind
of
extreme or insatiable hunger both of
these scenarios are very likely to
result in the opposite of your intention
when it comes to
going on a weight loss diet but what
about those of us who tend to eat
too much i think that a lot of us can
agree that the food industry often
pushes
large portions and most people don't
need to supersize
every part of every meal but as
intuitive eaters
it really shouldn't matter if you're
served a giant plate of pasta
or a 12-ounce steak if you're in tune
with your hunger fullness and
satisfaction cues
then you would just naturally stop
eating when you're satisfied
as the co-author of the intuitive eating
book evelyn tripoli says
portion control is not a problem for
intuitive eaters
since you're tuning into what your body
wants and needs in that moment
you no longer need to rely on counting
calories or feeling tied to a certain
portion
or amount of food your body in fact can
guide you
i mean it may be annoying that you've
overpaid for something that you won't
necessarily eat
but there are ways to manage this like
packing up leftovers or splitting the
meal with a friend
another reason that some people eat past
the point of fullness
is distraction so if you're always
eating while playing on your phone
answering emails or watching tv then it
is very hard to pay attention to our
fullness cues
or even just enjoy food in general this
is why i definitely suggest
limiting distractions during meals my
bet is that you'll be way more likely to
pick up on some of those early signals
i'd also pay attention to when you eat
past the point of fullness
what is going on there were you raised
in a household that emphasized
cleaning your plate did you not eat
enough earlier on in the day so you were
starving when you finally got a chance
to sit down
are you still having guilty thoughts
around food that you're eating so
let me talked about mental restriction
so instead of judging yourself for
eating
too much start to get curious about
what may have played a role in that
particular eating experience
and remember be non-judgmental finally
let's talk about food quality before i
start it's really important that we take
all of this information with a grain of
salt and only use
what suits you best remember that you
should never
ever feel guilty about eating any food
and this section
is not me telling you what you have to
or you
should eat but rather just some basics
of nutrition
that we know generally may result in
greater satiety
and greater satisfaction so tip one is
to add in a variety of vegetables
and fruits i'm sure you're told all the
time about the benefits of vegetables
and fruit but why what is so great
about veggies and fruit well first of
all these kinds of foods are rich in
fiber which is really important
for gut and heart health as well as for
increasing satiety
they're also loaded with lots of
vitamins and minerals
that may help to lower the risk of
chronic disease like heart disease
and cancer research also suggests that
compounds and produce known as
phytochemicals
act as antioxidants in the body to help
protect the body from harmful compounds
known as free radicals
year by year we're learning more and
more about the importance of
phytochemicals in the body
but simply put they keep our cells
protected
and can ultimately help to reduce the
risk of disease
now you don't need to just eat raw
veggies to reap benefits
in fact i actually encourage you to get
really creative in the kitchen
here are some ways to add some more
veggies and fruit to your diet
some my favorite ways to add veggies and
fruit to the diet are things like
ratatouille
vegetable stir fry with rice homemade
soup with leftover veggies or
frozen veggies stuffed bell peppers
stuffed baked potatoes
quesadillas or fifitas salad on the side
of a main meal
or a large salad as your meal just of
course
making sure to add other foods with some
proteins and some fat
some fruit and veggie smoothies pancakes
or waffles with a little fruit compote
on top
pasta sauce with lots of chopped veggies
in there or
if you have kids and you don't like the
texture you can also blend the
vegetables into a smoother pasta sauce
the sky is the limit the key with
vegetables and fruit is to add them
to your diet in a way that you actually
enjoy don't look at adding them for diet
reasons
i mean it's amazing how many people
start to enjoy vegetables and fruit once
they add it to their diet
in a delicious and unique enjoyable way
tip two
is to eat more fatty fish this one may
not apply to
all of you since you may choose to avoid
animal products or maybe you just don't
enjoy the taste of fish
totally fair but fish is rich in omega-3
fats particularly epa
and dha which are key for our overall
health
these fats support our brain heart and
skin
unfortunately most people just don't get
enough in their diet so
i do encourage you to try to add fish to
your menu
at least once or twice a week and if you
don't think that's doable
you may want to consider taking an
omega-3 supplement which
are available both fish-based and
algae-based online
tip 3 drink enough fluids most people
are not drinking enough
and are mildly dehydrated all the time
this can cause people to feel hungry or
even lethargic at times
while all beverages are allowed i would
try to focus mainly on drinking good old
water throughout the day
a good tip is to fill a water bottle and
carry it with you throughout your day
while some guidelines suggest two to
three liters per day
a good goal is to drink enough so that
you don't feel thirsty
or have signs of dehydration like
feeling light-headed
having pale skin concentrated urine etc
tip 4 have a loose structure around
meals and snacks just like nutrition
isn't thrown out the window with
intuitive eating
a structure around meal planning doesn't
have to go either
having some framework around meals and
snacks can help make the school or work
week easier
and less stressful by helping you feel
prepared think about the general
structure of your meal or snacks
including some protein carbohydrates
fiber
and fat you can also plan on grocery
shopping for fun
satisfying foods to of course keep in
the house or have on hand for some
snacks
if planning ahead is helpful you could
make a list of foods that you really
like in each of those kinds of
categories
and then basically just mix and match to
come up with some creative recipes for
meals and snacks
one thing i like to do is to look up one
or two ingredients that i have on hand
in order to find a recipe idea
or a little inspiration for days that
i'm feeling stuck
the key word here is loose structure
meaning not every meal will have each of
these components
and that is totally okay you don't need
to batch cook and line
everything up in identical tupperware
but having a general structure of
how to build a meal that satisfies you
and fills you up
may make the process easier tip 5
zoom out and look at the bigger picture
diet culture sells us on worrying and
stressing over
individual nutrients and the extreme
effects of each
aspect on our food choices but really
overall habits and patterns as well as
aspects aside from nutrition
are way greater indicators of overall
health yes
we have research to show that certain
foods promote health
and can prevent disease and choosing to
incorporate those foods
is a great example of gentle nutrition
but zooming out
can also help you look at your overall
diet composition and patterns
are there areas that you'd like to add
in more nutrient-dense foods
are there times when you'd like to be a
little bit more flexible around your
food choices
are there times when you're left feeling
unprepared or uninspired with meals and
snacks that you'd like to explore a
little bit more
to ensure that these choices don't come
from a place of restriction
or residual diet mentality it's
important to remember that
no one food or meal determines our
health which is also why
all foods can fit and can support a
healthy diet
so how to keep the pleasure in healthy
eating well to finish up this video i
really want to reiterate the importance
of focusing on pleasure when eating if
you don't enjoy food you're going to
have a really hard time practicing
intuitive eating
remember that listening to your body not
only involves staying in touch with
satiety levels
but also asking yourself these really
important questions
do i really like the taste of the food
that i'm eating
or am i just eating it for diet reasons
how does eating this food
make my body feel how do i feel when i
eat consistently in this manner
can i sustainably do this over time do i
feel
more or less energized after eating this
if eating healthy is both a pleasurable
experience
and makes you feel your best then you're
more likely to continue
honoring your health with your food
choices remember that it's not about
deprivation
it's about including foods that make you
feel your best
sometimes that's going to be a salad and
sometimes that's going to be chocolate
both are totally fine choices and should
never make you feel guilty
foods may not be nutritionally equal but
remember that we can make them
morally equal in the book by evelyn
tripoli and elise resch
they provide an intuitive eating bill of
rights which i think is a really great
way to end off this series
you have the right to savor and enjoy
your meal with
zero judgment you have the right to have
seconds
without explanation you have the right
to honor your fullness
and say no thank you if somebody offers
you
more food you do not have to explain
yourself
it's not your responsibility to make
somebody happy by overeating
even if they spent hours making it
you are always allowed to eat it later
if you want more you can have
whatever you want for breakfast lunch or
dinner
and not feel bad for it you want cereal
for dinner one day
go for it want leftover pizza for
breakfast go for it remember that
you are in charge of your life and your
body
no one knows how you feel except for you
only you are the expert of your body and
always always remember that
with all that said this week's homework
is to practice enforcing
the intuitive eating bill of rights
perhaps pick
one right each day to really embrace
over time you'll be able to embrace each
one without
even thinking about it for a moment but
remember it does take
time and that is totally okay finally i
want to say
a big thank you to evelyn tribally and
elise resh for writing such
a fabulous inspiring book definitely
purchase it below by visiting the link
in the description and i promise you you
will not be disappointed
on that note that is all for today folks
if you like this video be sure to give
it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
with any questions that you have on
intuitive eating
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
[Music]
bye
you